FDA is different than the rest of the
world and that we regulate sunscreen as
a drug instead of a cosmetic it's
regulated as a drug has far more
stringent standards now that was AOC
complaining that the fda's regulations
on sunscreen make it way too difficult
to approve new products in the U.S now
this time AOC is right it actually
sounds like a Libertarian the FDA does
in fact treat sunscreen like a drug
which means Federal bureaucrats can slow
down the approval process Regulators
have an okay to new sunscreen in more
than 20 years things are different in
Asia and Europe where Regulators have
allowed sunscreen manufacturers to add
many more ingredients to their products
according to the Cato Institute the EU
has approved 27 sunblocking ingredients
the FDA has approved just 17. even
though many people prefer products with
the other ingredients so good on AOC for
making government bureaucrats sweat